hi everyone its Johanna here and today's
workout it's called the natural bum lift
workout that's right you don't have to
go through any surgeries to get a nice
bump like you know Kim Kardashian or
even people Middleton but instead we'll
be having a lot of fun to give your butt
a nice lift so let's get started so I
ready the first workout will be to me
it's called sumo squat and side leg
raise so instead of your ordinary squats
where your toes are facing forward for a
sumo squat take a white step you know
just like someone that's getting ready
for a fight keep your toes facing
outwards and make sure that you know
you're taking white step what you want
to be doing is to squat down same thing
give your body up straight and when
you're up just extend your legs by the
side what this workout is doing is
basically to really to another bump then
inner thighs at the same time and also
the cheek of your bum when you're doing
the side race okay ready
so keep your hands by your waist if you
want to or you can extend it out for
extra support ready let's go more feet
toes facing out down and that's it down
and right good keep going
can you feel your inner thighs and the
cheetah rebound working that's right
really bring the legs all the way up we
are extending it to the side down and
down and up
go low no cheating love up down and
squeeze it when you're pushing up keep
your toes straight and push up with the
heels down and good keep going we've
just started make sure you're in a
superposition
down and up good job to me well I love
this soon as what it's one of my
favorite for Delly to really work that
inner thighs and also keep going doing
good come on let's go ah ah
bastard five more sets one two three
oops s two three four squeeze that bum
come on Braca for this nice bum five and
good job so that was the first button
workout
feeling it so let's move on to our
second workout which is called lunges
with kickbacks so your regular lunge
position when you're going down and when
you're coming back up kick back with
your back legs that's right
let's go that's it really squeeze that
bum knee kicking up kick it good
kick it good can you feel the lower part
of your ball working that's good and at
the same time your right leg should be
feeling the burn kick it good keep going
come on let's work out put it in the
lease term thumb pull your toes up when
you're kicking that's it just like a
ballerina
kick kick last five one two
three last two keep your balance or I'll
last one five that's it so let's change
sight I'll be facing friends now all
right so take your left leg forward
right leg back ready go
down kick down ah
that's it really view your left your
right bone squeezing and your left legs
should be feeling the way to help you in
Taiwan eight kick good keep going
make sure your body's in a straight line
go as low as you can
that's it good hello hello Anna
no cheating all the way up all the way
down up your knees should not be going
over your toes down and that's it ah
keep going last one one two three cake
for squeeze em up
take your legs and your bum working
good good good job for a third breakout
we'll be lying down with that and tell
you so I think is I am can you just see
it right let's go lie down looking at
okay bend your knees keep your knees
keep it down heels slightly close to
your body all right relax your arms and
what you want to be doing is to extend
one leg up toes pointing towards the
ceiling and just leave your palm up and
lower it down that's it up and every
squeezed upon when you're lowering it
down make sure that you're not going all
the way down and touching before always
keep that resistant and tension going
that sit up dumb cute licks your right
leg straight up and good job up and then
that's it up double live it up up and
down really feel that that bottom of
your spurning and working away together
with a hamstring up and oh my god my mom
is giving me up and up and down five
more one two good job three last two
pointers for last one and five whoo just
relax
all right good job now change legs so
left leg up
ready and go up and say the really
crucial fold all the way up letting a
stream pulling your belly dancing all
the way up and just squeeze your bum
that's it bring those up and feel your
white bottom working out and you're
right hamstrings as well up and your man
but imagine that's a string pulling your
body up and lowering down pulling up and
lowering it down no resting keep going
up and up good job out and dumb come on
you're almost there up and down up and
down last five one two last three 0.63 4
plus 1 5 5 and now just shake your legs
shake your bum and just relax all right
let's go we've got one more workout to
go and for this workout we'll be using
the wall okay so it's couple holes once
everybody knew
everybody hates it but it really works
about so let's get on to the wall okay
and similar to a squat position bring
your legs forward slightly when you're
squatting down your legs should feel 90
degrees with the toes facing forward and
that's it
no going up and down and just hold it
ready put your arms for for extra
support keep it on your waist
but do not put it in your knees because
you're trying to support the weight
all right let's hold it for 30 seconds
and that's it let's go just breathe
relax think of a beautiful place that
you want to go to your by the beach
right now
and I'm sweating oh my god
tastes like a tropical right now keep
going
really squeeze your bum really squeeze
your bum go low return we can lower it
down challenge yourself slightly keep
holding ah sweating relax
free online 10 seconds 9 8 day good 7 6
5 4 3 2 1 oh that's in Africa oh my god
I'm literally drinking right now just
shake your legs off just really just
shake it off because you've done such a
good job alright but what is what so
remember if you do not know any of these
moves
check out my how-to video where I'll be
explaining each move in details and you
know to show you the right technique
also don't forget to subscribe to my
YouTube page for more fitness and
nutritional advice so I've hope I've
worked your bum up well bye
you